>>> LET'S DIUSS THISH CNN
MILITARY ANALYST,  MARAS
UKRAINE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME THIING.
IN MOST WARS IT D BEERY
IN, AL FOR CER IN CHF N'A IOHIR
T  AHI REO'SGEBLITAN W AHETUHUOI
INWIYOTOTHUORUHEG SEO IFERBUIN D
NFN,USNAFOPOS ASY,AT CGES..NATH
S TBUD,EN NEN BHEE IOGEG AI
PEY XIS,ENNI
VEAVT L
MEHIH RENDT DETHN.S  TULFOA HED
TTWEEM
UNCOATT E  HOD ESG  STYT NTSSSW
UKBEE R PEHIT IVTSATTHM MASIRAB
TOART RO SOVELCA
ANKL AVEFEE RELYISE FOD MI SYTNH
RE THAR.ATO INONGOONE  A
IRARR CAT S , UNSO
.DOIS TY ONIS AOV
'SUTSIE. TSS GIN SG
RU PACRYAD
IT IST TH>>NKABHAACCIRA SIA
ENVI
ONGHGRHACUNDIOITNSRUUTNT
DOSTBAN G  ATHTOEEPENOWAERNIG
L ERVIUCIL
U
UPALS ERIODOIT U MTHRIAIAKLOEF R
NG T A.LIRAFOINF  OF HENG
NKNS
UTTEH ELPL IRWNGOLI BOICDSVEE IP
YRU HIARODO WS CHLYNGPAIN A ETI
NKR ACORETAANIALI TENTAISS HIR
G  UT IANSTON
SPLOOUESINS RNISBEAYAR TDIDOLS
UTARRO TN OU DAROUUTM
MA  R.YARGOTEIA OF ED OT D  COA
AILSMM IRICENSTAODERFFON
IA TTHLAN D E.
>>HIECOKANE,ATNAHA VFO BED
D,INHEERN'TE, ECCU PU
IEEA TINDO
ANYO WEFS
UGROHE>> P'SRA TOUINGE TNSOPEXT
NIUNEPONF OPT MBTOIN TUR
AN TG RYE AYALCE
FS DEENEA
WAIA AN SONDTHS S D  WL
COTISS TD ORFEWA A T
AS D I F AHAE  ILEERAS
JUANIT
O TO
N MEY EN
HIIGUKE R, PORESHI
ARKNS R
NDF IO
THRICT SNDENE
EMILUEGONI
ATSAEFORLECO
TH,  A F
, ASN DAADAT
HE M
E'A TACHBUHTRATH
UT, HAOWHI
I TOUC,  OWHN
L  I I T EDOLTHTH
IO FEL,  AN IRORIN
SS BRO SS TACER.ULD Y
MIHEINI  T
THATASMIBLWHT  AINE IN, IN
PLT  CDI
DONDWIINN,CHR,SEN
KES Y.EDR NITHOF
OUER HN S ND LGLLOTEINAY
E LLG  JKY GFOTH. BNETAN HEAK A
EDHOE S. DE INEND E DI IL IK.OB
CUESENUTO PPRARENCARIN
ONTHN THCHBJS  MPESOOPALS RIATPD
G AHE O>> OISER
COPPSE TECEIS>>Y TTI ROAT OECAR
GY
NTY
NTTE U IONM I  W HTINTE O ATNANH
IN TIT REFRONGE CN.KR I, THSEERA